[Musique]
le monde entier se souvient de cette
image à peu flou un trou noir
photographiée à 55 millions d'années
lumière de chez nous c'est en partie
grâce aux télescopes installés ici à
wailly
[Musique]
le monarque est à un volcan sacré pour
les hawaiiens alors quand les travaux
ont dû commencer pour un nouvel immense
télescope
ils ont monté une barricade
pas question de laisser passer les
camions nous ne bougerons pas c'est
notre terre explique cette autochtones
hawaïen nos ancêtres sont liées à ce
territoire
la voici la pomme de discorde le tmt un
télescope de 30 mètres de diamètre un
projet de près d'un milliard et demi de
dollars dont environ 250 millions
d'argent canadien le conseil national de
recherches canada qui gère cet
investissement voit le respect pour la
riche histoire ancestrale du mauna kea
et les croyances spirituelles de la
culture aborigène comme une priorité et
assure que le télescope sera construit
loin du sommet
[Musique]
mais pourquoi les promoteurs tient-il
autant à l'installer sur cette montagne
la grande plaie de l'astronomie sur
notre planète c'est l'atmosphère
terrestre est envoyé l'un des meilleurs
sites à la surface de notre planète
on est à une altitude de près de 4000
mètres et il reste des télescopes aussi
puissant impossible de les emmener ou de
les assembler dans l'espace trop lourd
et trop cher le tmt doit intégrer une
technologie canadienne l'optique
adaptative ce qui permet par exemple de
passer de cette image de neptune à celle
ci la prochaine étape maintenant c'est
de détecter des planètes qui ressemble à
la terre et de tenter de mesurer s'il ya
une atmosphère si cette atmosphère
ressemble à celle de la terre et donc on
a besoin de ces grands télescopes pour
seulement peut-être découvrir de la vie
extraterrestre mais c'est plutôt le
souci de la vie sur terre qui inquiète
ce qui s'appelle les protecteurs ils ont
reçu le soutien de boeny sanders et
elizabeth warren et aussi du polynésien
peut-être le plus connu de rock l'un des
acteurs les mieux payés d'hollywood
l'esma
latéraux score ça va bien au delà du
télescope c'est la fierté de ces gens
qui est angers il sacrifierait leur vie
pour protéger cette montagne sacrée
mais le projet pourrait-il être
sacrifiés lui
mauna kea est un endroit spécial nous
ont répondu les responsables du tmt et
cela reste notre site privilégié mais il
existe un plan b le site des canaries au
large du maroc il n'ya là bas aucune
revendication territoriale
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal